cancer is like a car crash your body
typically regulates the speed at which
your cells divide but sometimes cancer
cuts the brake lines and your cells
divide too quickly accumulating
mutations that cause them to veer away
from their original function form
dangerous tumors and land you in the
hospital cancer is basically an
inability of the body to control the
speed at which cells divide when cells
divide too quickly they can often
accumulate mutations that cause them to
ignore their original function in the
body forming tumors in turn these tumors
may interfere with the natural processes
of the body such as digestion and
respiration potentially leading to death
typically your body has a number of
genetic mechanisms to control how fast
your cells divide one of these genes is
brca1 which stands for breast cancer
susceptibility gene one brca1 belongs to
a class of genes called tumor suppressor
genes tumor suppressor genes are
involved in regulating how fast a cell
divides normally cell division follows
an orderly process called the cell cycle
which is basically the life cycle of a
cell within the cell cycle is a series
of checkpoints where proteins such as
the one produced by brca1 regulate how
fast the cell may proceed how does it do
this
brca1 helps repair some forms of
mutation in your DNA if your DNA is
damaged brca1 keeps the cell from
dividing until the mutation is repaired
you have two copies of the brca1 gene in
every cell of your body
one copy you inherited from mom the
other from dad this redundancy is a good
thing because you only need one
functioning brca1 gene in a cell to
regulate the cell cycle but it's
important to note that while these
copies have a similar function they're
not necessarily the same in fact there
are hundreds of variations or alleles of
brca1 some regulate the cell cycle more
effectively than others in other words
some people are born with better
regulating and repair
mechanisms than others and in some cases
mutations may render brca1 ineffective
when this happens cells with damaged DNA
are allowed to divide as they divide
these cells may accumulate additional
mutations these mutations may cause the
cell to become less specialized and stop
performing its original function in the
tissue if this occurs then there's a
greater chance they'll develop into
cancer cells while we all have the genes
such as brca1 that can cause cancer it's
only when these genes fail at their
function that problems develop having an
ineffective or mutated version of brca1
can increase your susceptibility to
cancer much like driving with bad brakes
increases the risk of an accident
you